facial recognition perhaps one of the
biggest technological advances in recent
years
but what happens when technology like
this falls into the wrong hands
along with many other technologies like
high performance computers
drones and specialist software facial
recognition will soon fall into a
category known as dual use goods
that means while they all have
legitimate civil uses
they could also be abused by military
repressive regimes
or even terrorists the export of
european dual use goods outside the eu
is strictly controlled and parliament is
voting on rules
for the 21st century i think this is a
huge success for the
human rights we managed with this
regulation to considerably
increase uh transparency requirements
which means that we will know what we
are exporting
and to whom or at least to which country
the new rules will add cyber
surveillance technologies like facial
recognition to the dual use list
mep successfully pushed for the rules to
include human rights violations
as a justification for refusing export
licenses
along with more traditional dual use
items like chemical precursors for
making explosives or lasers
the updated legislation means the eu has
some of the safest dual use controls in
the world
you